how's it going guys today we're going to
look at how to arrange your c
plus projects this is all about folder
structure include source resources all
that so
full disclosure and as not to hide
anything this here is the plan
right there so we're going to talk about
how to organize your project this might
be a series i'm going to try to cover it
all in just one video here
and we'll see how that goes so c plus
plus arrangement
methods let's start with making
libraries
okay so i have written here the standard
is public headers go and include
project name everything else goes in
source so let me show you
an example so we head right on over to
github here and we're just going to look
at a few different ones let's check out
asim which is an open asset importer
library repository that's kind of hard
to say
so this is a very uh very public library
that's used very frequently for
loading 3d models and your your code it
pulls in all the
whatever you know so let's take a look
at how it's arranged
so it's got this big this is uh
the structure of it but what we're
interested in is the
code section because it's got a lot of
additional stuff
i guess actually they include so this is
the public part if you're including and
linking this libraries
which is another topic this is what you
need
you need all these headers to include in
your project
so you and the reason it's in this
subfolder of the project name is
so you have clarity of what exactly is
being included because if you're just in
including bitmap bitmap from what but
now if it's asim slash bitmap you know
it's from asim
so that is the point of having the
project name the same with all this
other stuff you can find lots of
examples online
how to use this library it's not really
what this is about i'll do some more
tutorials on how to use libraries later
i just want to talk about structuring
projects so if you're building your own
this is how you want to do it okay so
just launching my uh
little game engine here thing that i've
been working on real quick and i just
want to show you
how it's all included in my project and
just an example
of acid being used what is with this
this
is not the last theme i chose i don't
know why it looks like this
let's go to dark okay so um
well i guess here's another example so
my library here
this aaa engine is a library it's like a
game engine helper library basically
and i also do the same thing following
the standard for this library
include ancient archer and there is the
main header
the one and only is a utility which you
don't need to use but as
a someone who's using this library these
would include that and i'm also
using asim in here in some places now
this is still being worked out this
isn't like
necessarily the best example in the
world but let's just take a look if
i go to like my model loader here which
is and my renderer i think
model loader you can see when i include
asim of course i gotta include that
because otherwise it would just be
importer
and who knows what that is right so
that's why you put it
in the include and then the project name
again just so it's clear
where it's coming from so and what do
you do with your source well
most people just put it in the source
and then you structure your other files
these are all private all your public
headers
should be here everything else private
headers etc
go in there so let me just see how
they're doing it here on
assemp if we back up a few it looks like
rather than
source they're calling it code so this
code is all the private code
and uh yeah everything else is just
extra stuff
stuff sample scripts whatever their
build stuff all that
but we're only talking about the code
here in this video
maybe we want to look at another example
let's look at glm which is a header only
library
glm oh we're uh in all of github
here uh let me find the right
one this is it
group i don't think that is it i don't
know this might be
uh this is probably an old version of it
but we'll see a similar thing here
we'll see um well this is a little
different because it's a header only
library
so you just include this base thing and
then when you want to actually
use something it's still you still
access it through
glm whatever but since this is header
only they don't have the include folder
so take note of that if it's header only
library
you're not necessarily going to have the
include folder because the whole thing
is the include folder basically
i guess in this case that's a little bit
of a different case here
okay let's look at another one let's
look at the poco library which is uh c
plus plus libraries for building network
stuff
and we'll see a very similar thing here
so
they have a ton of stuff in here and
let's just see what we can find do they
have an include folder
include no so they're doing something a
little differently here
let's just click around it looks like
they have different sections here
what do they have source that's all cpp
so some of these are going to be a
little bit different
i guess uh
let's find it it's gotta be in here
somewhere
okay so if i go back to my project and i
just give it a quick test by going okay
so if i go to include let the
intellisense kick in
and i see poco there it is
so and then what and then you go to
whatever it is
so it looks like it might be the case
here that they aren't necessarily doing
it the standard way
on this particular library so your
results may vary a little bit
and we're going to talk more about
libraries here in a second
now i'm a little curious how they have
this so it might be in the build
i don't know i don't know what they're
doing here i honestly don't understand
this library right off so usually they
should have an include folder
of all their public stuff it appears
they're doing it a little differently
here
but it looks like it's sorted out and so
you're just going to have to analyze
case by case but in general include
project name
go from there and everything else goes
in your source or code folder now
so that's for making libraries you want
to do that that's
people are always going to know this in
general c plus plus programs if you're
doing something different if you're
going against the grain that might be
fine maybe you found a better way
but this tends to be pretty clear it
looks like poco found a different way
so just digging into this poco a little
bit now i must admit that i haven't
really used poco a lot so i'm not super
familiar with it maybe it wasn't the
best one for me to pick because of that
but i just went into this folder called
redis which is probably redistribution
and they do have
an include in here so it might be the
case that they have
uh poco somewhere here or net and then
include yeah here it is so i guess it
depends what section of it it looks like
there's a bunch of sub libraries within
poco
so you'll see that too so it looks like
if you want to use the net stuff
you got to include this folder here this
include and then you'll be
including poco net slash whatever h and
you'll see these are all h files or no
cpp files because these are all public
headers
so it takes a little analysis to figure
it out if it's a bigger library with a
bunch of different sections
but it looks like that's the case in all
of them you just go into one of the
different sections
and you can see that they have that
include and then the project
name again all right well let's move on
to the next thing and that's about
applications how do you section or how
do you make your application so we're
kind of ignoring libraries for a second
we will come back to including libraries
don't worry so i'll talk more about that
so stay tuned okay application so your
different options here you can do
folders per class or folders per section
pure flat or headers for everything with
one main file that all the headers built
into
and we'll we'll talk about these a
little bit let's kind of go in order
here i'm going to actually just close
this
we're going to open a
terminal i guess yeah we're going to
open a terminal and i'm just going to
make a directory called demo project cd
demo project
now keep in mind i'm using the windows
special terminal here maker only exists
because
i have installed wsl
just fyi all right so let's talk about
this folders per
class so in this case if you're making
an application
not a library this is like you know a
standalone application that runs not for
other people to include
it's just to do your main thing
you'll do something like this now you
can keep it you can keep all your code
on the root level that's somewhat fine
that would be somewhere along the lines
of pure flat but what
most people usually do is they make a
directory called code
or they make a directory called source
where they make a directory called
source spelled out it doesn't matter i
prefer src
personally that's what i like to do
these days but that changes so i'm going
to go into that directory
we're going to do a clear
and there's nothing in it we're just
just in this path all right so next what
we want to do here
is uh so let's do the example of folders
per class
let's say we have our main data class so
we'll just make an
another directory within here called uh
we'll just call it data i know it's
really generic it should have a better
name
but i'm just i'm just going to use data
what does it like about this oh i
spelled it wrong
maker data helps to spell your commands
wrong so these are kind of linux
commands for
for windows with powershell well you're
probably just going to create folders
with whatever id you're using
or you can right click and create a new
folder
with new folder or you can do this make
dirt thing if you have wsl and you're
using the windows new windows terminal
or there's so many ways you can do like
there's like a new item i forget what it
is you can look up just google
powershell create folder command and
you'll find it and
you can find that command for any of
these if you're not sure and you want to
get good at it just takes practice
all right but we're going to stick with
the linux commands because those are the
ones i'm most used to and they're
working
so let's talk about folders per class
again we made the directory data if we
do a list we see it
so we're going to go into data and then
we'll we'll just make some files now i'm
going to use
i think it's let's see if touch works
data.cpp
and data.h doesn't like that
hold on let me look this up okay so also
you can also just make these by right
clicking and do new file but it likes to
make them as like text files or
something predetermined or you might
have an ide that's just
you might have like a create class
button within your ide that's fine
but if you want to do it all in the
command line i guess you got to do this
new dash item and then you do a path
item value so we're just going to do
data.h
there it makes it new dash item
data.cpp and then when we edit these i'm
going to use visuals
to not visuals yeah visual studio code
um data.h data.cpp
and that should launch them with
individual studio code here it's
probably going to yell at me for updates
and install stuff whatever i'm not going
to do that
so then you would start designing up
your classes and just real quick i'll do
a do a quick example here
so right so public we have a constructor
a destructor a set the data with and
we're just using integer for the data
and uh we're using a get data now notice
uh this
i could you know we could have a get
data
that something more like uh returns
the integer and doesn't take anything
here so that's just something that
a lot of people like to do i like to say
you pass a reference to what you want to
fill
that way you don't have to return
anything so that's what this get data is
and this one would actually return it
and now notice we don't have the
definitions here we would
do them in the associated cpp so we have
this
data.h pragma what's the top very nice
and we go over here
and we would do include and then
data.h and this is where we would do all
our definitions
so just work those up real quick i'll
just fill them out fast enough so that
would actually compile
like this would actually compile but we
want to do something like this one would
be data equals
the data
the data and because it's just uh you
know
you it's a reference to this piece so
that it would just fill it out with
whatever it is that's one way of
returning
but also do return the data
and this one where it returned an
integer and it's just that these getters
and setters are totally optional some
people don't like to use them at all and
they just like to leave everything
public that's totally up to you and your
project now you're doing it
so empty constructor mp destructor or
you know you can do whatever you need to
do there
of course this one here would just be
something like
the data equals data so that's like a
quick way
you have your whole class in a subfolder
so now if we look at this
see we got the our data and of course
this would be something else we'll go
back a directory
we now have that data folder and nothing
else but we still need to like compile
it into a main because every project
needs a main so where do you put your
main usually when you do it this way you
just put it
right on the the root of source
so i'm going to go new item main.cpp
also this doesn't need to be called
main.cpp it's just kind of the standard
to call it that
so another fyi there's a lot of this
stuff that is like
just standard but now if we want to
include it we got to go
into that data folder and then data
again which might be a little weird
so i don't prefer to do it this way
honestly because just like
saying the same thing twice seems weird
to me i'd rather do a flat structure
but just you can do it so now we can
instantiate data
okay so now that we've got it filled out
and we should be able to get an
answer here you know there's other ways
of filling out this what is we could go
what is equals data dot
get data you know stuff like that so
a lot of options here to fill that out
but uh
so you would just fill it out you would
keep making more of these
folders per class and then a reason
people like to do this sometimes
is because in this data class or yeah
within this data class
maybe you eventually have some helpers
that go along with it or some sub
structs that it needs or something like
that so you could include them
in this folder as well and kind of start
sectioning it off which brings me to the
next section
um folders per section
so the folders per class often turns
into folders per section
then it starts to make a little more
sense why you would do this
and then there's pure flat so let's talk
about pure flat real quick pure flat's
pretty
pretty straightforward i'm going to
close all these for a second
and we're going to just look at this and
we're going to go
actually we're just going to go move
data
dot star backer directory now when we
look in here
it's empty so let's go back directory
and we'll see that everything's now
flat and we could go i think it's delete
the data folder yeah it's gone so now
everything's in a flat
structure we can just open this whole
folder
like so and of course now we can just
get rid of this
so what happens with a flat structure is
you end up with a giant list of files
all in one folder
and most people actually prefer that
it's a little easier you just don't have
to worry about pathing to your stuff all
the time
but it's totally optional both are valid
strats
and it just depends how you want to do
it so those are some of the different
ways
you can kind of organize your project
per class per section now of course keep
in mind when you're giving your compiler
commands
if you're not using some ide for
compiling if you're using an ide it
might be automatic but if you're using a
make file
or creating your own g plus plus build
command
you've got to be sure to path to your
stuff so it'd be like main.cpp
data.cpp and then you're out to be
whatever it's going to automatically do
it i don't think i have g
i don't have that installed i might not
have this installed or something
or i might have to launch one of my wsl
linux things to do that but uh so i had
to i'd have to build
like ms build i don't want to get into
that too much i can maybe do another
video
all about compiling i think i have one
actually if you search my channel for c
plus plus compilers it should be the
very first episode on my c plus plus
series
so fyi i go into a lot of that but i
don't want to do here we're just talking
about structuring
so here's another way the third way
um and just to go back to this another
benefit of doing this
per just section it off per class
is each of these cpps builds builds
their own object so as things
change within your project it only
rebuilds the objects it needs to rebuild
which can save you compile time because
if you have say five different classes
and you change one of them
it will only rebuild that one class and
then it will link everything together
and make your executable
but this other way i'm about to talk
about doing it is headers for
everything this is where you only have
one cpp file usually a main
and you build everything into one giant
object
so it's kind of nice because
well okay i'll show you why it's kind of
nice so if you look at this
you'll notice that we have we're
duplicating code here
like we're putting set data here and
we're saying set data again here and
we're just duplicating
lots of text and there are reasons for
that mainly because like the header only
wants to know about the function
but it just needs to exist somewhere
within your program but for other stuff
to call it it just needs to know about
it
in this header type form so that's just
the way c plus plus is
but one thing you can do is you can take
all these definitions
and put them within your header like so
and have no associated c plus file
and then when you go here into your main
as it includes it it's going to build
into this
so this will still work but if you make
another c
plus file and also include data you're
going to get multiple
or redefinition errors so you got to
watch out for that you truly only need
to have one and there's another
problem you can run into it if you do
this too if you have a bunch of files i
guess i can
we can just hit this plus button to make
new files let's say we have uh
let's call it other data dot h and we'll
do a little pragma
brag what once here and we'll work up
another class i'll do real quick
okay so i just made another class it's
essentially the same thing
i just named it other but the point i
want to make here
is if these classes require each other
you can run into some tricky stuff
because the order of the include starts
to matter so if for example other data
required data and this is a really odd
example to be honest because
i'm just calling it data and other data
but it might be more like in a real
example
if you have say uh say you're
structuring like
uh um inventory system
your inventory system might rely on
items and items might be another class
so that might be a better example but i
think this will make the point anyway
so now when you include data it doesn't
include other data
but if you include other data
here it's going to still include data
because it's going to go down this list
and it's going to say okay include data
and then do all this stuff now the thing
to realize that's very important here
is this include including one of your
header files
is a literal copy and paste so what this
include other data does is it does this
it grabs all this
and replaces it with like that that's in
your code now
so and then as you include another one
if you included data afterwards
it would it would be literally this so
it would be like you did include
data here theta.h
yeah you get it it will literally be
doing this
so it's literally just like piling all
this code in here but we haven't include
data here so it would also be doing it
right here
so you would get like this cascade of
weird inclusions that's kind of the
point of this fragment once
is it means only include it once but we
don't want to do any of that
we just want to you know i'm just
showing you how it works i guess here
we just want to include it and do its
thing but just so you know it's a
literal copy and paste and if you're
running into strange errors where it
doesn't see something
it might be because the one you're
including
is below so the order of the include can
matter
is the point i'm making here something
relies on something else it won't see it
unless you've included the other one
it relies on first so you just include
them as you go
and you can the other really nice thing
is you don't have to duplicate
this code in an associated cpp file it's
all right here the definitions right
here
it's all ready to go so reduces the
number of files
and it can make it a little cleaner a
lot of people like to do it this way
but there is a drawback to doing it this
way and that big drawback
is really that it's a single object
rebuild
so if you change one header the entire
object needs to rebuild
so as with this previous version if you
change one thing only the associated
piece would have to rebuild
but this thing no matter what you change
everything rebuilds so it can lead to
really long
recompile time so you make a little
change you recompile you're like oh
great it takes five minutes again
whereas your other way would be like oh
it only takes 10 seconds so in
really large projects this single object
rebuild can take a really long time and
small projects not that big of a deal
so just be aware of that
and another method which i haven't
really mentioned here is the
uh monolithic we call it monolithic
i think that's how you spell it well i
i've spelled that wrong the monolithic c
plus plus
file so some people will just go um
they'll just do everything in one file
they'll say
no screw headers screw messing with
files screw it screw everything
i'm mad at the world i don't want to
deal with c plus plus anymore i don't
want to deal with headers and classes
and files and
yada yada so they just go i'm only
having one main and i'm putting my
entire
program in it no matter how big it gets
so you end up with like
million line cpp files with all your
stuff
just cascading in here and it's
essentially the same as doing a bunch of
headers
if you change one thing the entire thing
has to rebuild but
i'm just going to call it monolithic
thick
yeah i went there all right so that's
another way that people actually do it
it is it works fine all these methods
work
fine you sure you can go on stack
overflow and and like talk about it or
ask questions about it and get harassed
these all get the job done you know how
to code you know how to structure stuff
you know how to build software if you
know how c plus plus works
these all get it done these all and
these all lead to final
finished apps so don't get
the point is don't get caught up in the
jargon your work and go with what you
like
i personally prefer the pure flat
these days i i even don't mind the
monolithic and headers for everything
until it starts to grow once it starts
getting bigger then you can kind of
section it off and
and as needed but if it compiles quickly
anyway it doesn't matter
all right so that's it for the whole
application section hopefully that was
helpful now we're going to talk about
one last part here and that is including
libraries i'm going to kind of make this
quick so
this is the this is leads back to
developing your apps as you're
developing your applications
eventually you're going to run into
something and kind of going back to my
making libraries thing you're going to
be like oh i want to do this or i want
to do that
but i don't want to spend like three
months of my life writing it so you just
want to use someone else's library that
already did it
and that's where including libraries
comes in and maybe you've
maybe you've wrote your own libraries to
handle stuff and you just want to
include your own
now i'm not going to get into the fine
details of the commands to pass into the
command line to link stuff that's for
another video i think i might have
covered in other videos
but the easiest way to do this is to use
a manager
vc package manager is probably the
easiest one if you're on windows
and this isn't talking about build
systems like c makes a
actually cmake is a build system
generator so
it's like a build system for built
system but we're not talking about that
here
we're talking about just how to get them
included so bc package manager conan
this
admittedly this is a pretty confusing
topic i would like to dive more into it
but i'll be here
all day and honestly i would i should
structure my stuff better before i start
talking about it so
well i'm just going to keep it simple
using the manager vc package manager
i'll link
leave a link somewhere down below i have
a video about it
there's other ones there's conan i
haven't personally used conan but i've
heard good things and it looks nice
they're very similar they're basically
like if you're familiar with the whole
node system that everyone uses it's sort
of like that
you just do is do the command for vc
package manager once you get it set up
it just has a command where you can do
stuff pc pkg
update etc so you can uh you can do all
your commands install your libraries
and it tells you how to link them or how
to
set them up with your build system so
basically
it handles building them for you and
handles pulling down the latest version
for you
and that sort of stuff you can also do
it manually which i've done some videos
on
as well i'll try to find one to link
there might be several different ones
that might be a bit scattered
but basically if you're doing it
manually you go download
the source code you build it and then
you link it and of course you include
the headers which should be
something like this so you can do it
manually for your projects too if you
want to have it all in
one nice chunk that you can pass around
your friends or whatever
and not have to worry about whether they
have a manager set up or not
you can also download the pre-built ones
and link that way
it skips the build section you just
download the pre-built
binaries is what you see them called
binaries so if you see pre-built
binaries
they've already done that it just
includes the header and the final object
that you have to link with your program
so that you can actually use the stuff
in the headers
so essentially the stuff
the pre-built ones well includes the
public headers but it includes
it doesn't include any of the private
source files it only includes the final
object that those built
into that way these includes actually
work because those
just point to them basically all right
another way to do is get sub modules
this is probably my favorite way to do
it if you're doing it manually
but you could you can basically point to
a repo on github
and then have the commands um set up
within
whatever your build system or pre-built
system is to automatically do it with
git sub modules i'll link a video to
that i think a lot of people found it
helpful so
it's kind of an eye opener if you've
never used get sub modules super nice
so yeah my two favorite or definitely
get sub modules and vc package manager
but this download and doing it manually
getting the binaries it's fine too
and is often nice because you don't have
to worry about things changing on you
with sub modules
sometimes you pull down the latest
version and update and break something
same with vc package manager
if you're doing it manually you will
kind of run you don't
necessarily run into that and the very
last thing i just want to touch on i
don't really want to talk about too much
is the build systems um in general
your ide accidentally spelled die
bidding for us programmers uh we're all
masochists right that's the meme
all right so you can use cmake you can
use premake you can rely on your ide to
set it up for you like visual studio
community edition pretty much does it
for you with ms build
xcode will do it automatically you can
set up
make files within most editors so this
is the whole topic on its own
but just know that there's some options
out there i have a tutorial on cmake if
you want to check that out
but otherwise i would suggest just using
visual studio
community edition or your favorite one
and just do some
some reading up on how to generally do
uh blank and build with that one because
once you learn one of them
really well the rest become a lot easier
because they're all very similar they
ultimately all do the same thing
they just run the build command in a
command like format which is just a long
gcc all your stuff and then all your
linker commands and um yeah it's just
all that they basically just handle
doing that for
you so pick your poison some people even
like to do it manually they'll create
just scripts or batch files that
have their commands so they know exactly
what's going on and it's not abstracted
behind some other
build system generator but the choice is
yours all right i hope this video has
been helpful
i've tried to rush through it i've tried
to make it as short as possible with as
much info as possible
so uh leave a like please i would
appreciate it and if you want to go the
extra mile sign up on patreon
help me keep making these videos for
free for you guys
by being one of the people that pays
that didn't come out how i intended but
oh well alright
peace out guys hope you have a good one
see in the next episode math go tech
tutorials over now